I'm a writer-director who tells social
sharing stories because I believe
stories touch and move us stories
humanized and teach us to empathize
stories changes when I write in direct
place I'm amplifying voices of
disadvantaged groups I'm fighting the
self censorship that has kept many
Ugandan artists away from Sher Shah
political theater since the persecution
of at ease by former ugandan president
idi amin and most importantly i am
breaking the silence and provoking
meaningful conversations on taboo issues
where often silence is golden is the
rule of thumb conversations are
important because they inform and
challenge our minds to think and change
starts with thinking one of my struggles
with activism it's often one sided
nature that blinds us to alternative
view that numbs our empathy that makes
us view those who see issues differently
has ignorant self-hating brainwashed
sellout or plain stupid I believe no one
is ignorant we are all experts only in
different fields and this is why for me
the saying stay in your truth is
misleading because if you're staying in
your truth isn't it logical that the
person you believe is wrong is also
staying in their truth so what you have
is two extremes that shut out all
possible avenues of conversations I
create provocative theatre and film to
touch humanize and move disagreeing
parties to the conversation table to
bridge misunderstandings I know that
listening to one another will not
magically so
all problems but it will give a chance
to create avenues to start to work
together to solve many of humanity's
problems with my first play silent
voices based on interviews with victims
of the northern Uganda war between the
government and Joseph Kony's lraa a
rebel group I brought together victims
political leaders religious leaders
cultural leaders amnesty commission and
transitional justice leadership for
critical conversations on issues of
justice for war crime victims the first
of its kind in the history of Uganda and
so many powerful things happen that I
can't even cover them all right now
victims were given the opportunity to
sit at the table with Amnesty Commission
leadership and they express the big
injustice they suffered when the
Commission ignored them and instead
facilitated the resettlement of the war
perpetrators an amnesty commission
acknowledged the victims pain and
explained the thinking behind their
flood approaches but one of the things
that has stayed with me is when during
my northern Uganda tour of the play a
man approached me and introduced himself
as a former rebel soldier of Joseph
Coyne he told me that he didn't want me
to leave feeling disappointed due to
some of what I considered inappropriate
laughter he explained that his was a
laughter of embarrassment and a
recognition of his own embarrassment he
saw himself in actors on stage and so
the meaninglessness of his past actions
so I say share your truth listen to one
another's truth you will discover a more
powerfully uniting truth in the middle
ground when I lived in the USA many of
my American friends would be shocked at
my ignorance at fancy Western dishes
like lasagna for instance and my
question to them would be
well do you know Malik Wong and then I
would tell them about Malik Wong a fancy
vegetable dish from my culture and they
would tell me about lasagna and we would
leave richer and fuller individuals
therefore share your recipe truth it
makes for a better meal thank you
[Applause]
[Music]